now Martin in Kent what are you cooking  along  [Applause]  I need help light I need help you need  help I need help with my cooking yeah I  do  I cooked once for my ex-girlfriend coin  that's the story basically she's my eggs  so as please help me I want to learn  from the best Gordon thank you so has  anyone who told you that you look a  little bit like me Gordon I get told a  lot but you know what I've got the look  but I can't cook  [Applause]  just out of interest okay just out of  interest  what do you do for a living what's your  day job me well I actually crikey I make  plastic Gordon so this is a long way  removed from cooking so they go good  melting tonight going to make three  delicious courses forget the plastic  stay with me right oh you scare me good